in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Justin
and Lauren are here hey guys how are you
great how are you Eve welcome welcome
where do you guys live just outside
Chicago in Hoffman Estates very fun very
fun well welcome to Nashville and who
have you got with you this is Sydney and
she's 7 months old mm-hmm and this is
Logan and he's 2 years and seven months
old that perfect age to run yeah it's uh
it's all about it's all about the fun at
that stage that's a good thing oh yeah
well they'll watch after him don't worry
we've not lost one yet it's good well
thanks for being here to do your debt
free scream how much of you guys paid
off we've paid off eighty four thousand
eight hundred and twenty seven dollars
and 81 cents now seventeen and a half
months oh now that's quick all right
making what kind of money we started at
1:43 and we finished at 222 Wow so you
went down no no 22 way up okay what do
you guys do for a living
she's the teacher I teach high school
and I'm currently teaching independent
living which is a consumer head class
and we teach foundations in personal
finance oh thank you the second year
we've been able to offer that to our
students very nice very cool all right
and so what do you do I'm an outside
sales no water treatment and you're
killing it yeah the least because 222
minus a teacher's salary yeah good way
to go man very blessed yes you are so
how did all this income increase happen
well actually I switched jobs about
three and a half years ago and then when
this process started it just kind of put
me in the high gear ah you had something
to fight for
yeah I I basically started listening to
you with the way that all started was
she actually told that um so it was our
son's first birthday and I'm gonna try
not to cry and we had invited all of our
friends and family over for his birthday
and I went to the store to start buying
food for the party and I was like how
are we gonna pay for this because we you
know we're running out of money
by the end of the month and we our
credit cards were kind of
to the point of there was no money left
and we ended up figuring out how to make
it work but at the same time I was like
I'm done I'm done yeah really
forty three thousand dollars I can't buy
groceries for my kids party exactly
McIntyre I'm officially mad like it
that's a story and a friend had
recommended dave ramsey to us and a
while back and i was like you know what
let's i'll just listen to the book and
see what happens so I listened to the
book and Justin came home that night
from work and I was like you have to
listen to this please like literally
begging him and he was like I don't okay
like that for the six years before that
she had been pushing me to do something
with our finances and I just fought it
and fought it and then that time I
listened to the book in the car between
sales calls and cancelled the rest of
the day and finished the book in about
four hours
Wow and then got home and walked in the
door and said grab all the credit cards
we're cutting them in half I think let's
do it right now she's like whoa on board
for so long and I'm the saver I'm you
know the nerd of the relationship and
he's more of the free spirit and so for
him to come home and be like nope work
we're doing this we're done and I was
like whoa wait so he only buys in all
the way yeah and we spend all ever since
that's so amazing
so Justin you're wired kind of like me
because I would have been cynical would
have had my shields up and when I tried
to do because I'm a sales got to I tried
to out-earn my stupidity for years oh
yeah and so what was your resistance to
doing not my plan but just a whole
financial plan when she's bringing that
up we need to do something with the
money when you do something money you're
like no no no no why remember why I'll
just sell more you were the next job I
can sell the next thing yes exact same
thing we bought a car that the whole
process of buying the car was well if I
sell this much we can afford the monthly
payment yeah so that's my goal each
month is to make sure we sold that and
then a little bit more and you know it
kind of got old so now he's got a whole
new goal and that's bumping the debt out
like crazy so did you guys just go
hard core beans and rice or did you sell
stuff a combination of both and in the
process we had her so that cost us some
money we paid to refinance the house
right I had I we did a six-week paid on
unpaid maternity leave there and then we
sold my truck which was really the baby
of the whole thing I that was what
probably put us in that position the
hardest position at the end and was part
of the reason we ended up going down
that path a bunch of the trucks all for
about thirty thousand Oh
we bought a 65 thousand dollar truck and
yeah financed the whole thing as much as
our friends mortgages that's how you
turn 65 into 30 yes yeah so yeah so that
was that was tough but that was the
biggest thing that we did and she was
surprised that came home I said it's
time to get rid of the truck she goes
but you worked your whole life to get
that truck and yeah I said our life's
more important than this truck and you
know what you get another one now Yeah
right
$25,000 you got no payments to save up
and buy a truck every minute now yeah I
mean you drive like no one else later
nothing you get to drive like no one
else you get to live like no one else
but more anything you guys have learned
to work together and completely I mean
the word that comes to mind it's a
religious word but I'm gonna use it
anyway repentance which means to turn
away you guys did a complete 180 in 24
hours oh yeah I mean you just went boom
turn the other way I mean that that's so
radical but your results are radical
oh yeah and everybody in Our Lives
thought we were crazy now everybody at
my work the whole time was thinking
we're nuts and just given giving me a
hard time and about a month and a half
ago once we were like at the end of this
process now they've all bought the book
now every meeting is about you questions
and Tuesday when I left to come down
here they're like no don't go work for
them or anything because we talk so much
but it's pretty funny just the way the
whole process goes and yeah it's been
awesome same at my work I have a number
of teachers that are like so wait tell
me more about this Dave guy and and it's
definitely in the kids I mean I am very
very open with the kids and I share my
story with them and I
to them I don't ever want you to be in
the position we were in I want why
that's why I'm so passionate about it
sometimes I think they're they think I'm
a little crazy but you know it is it is
what it is and you know they just kind
of roll their eyes sometimes being
teenagers but you know I try to stress
the importance of why it's so important
you have a clean slate now you know
focus on that and do well with your
money and cool to have a high school
teacher who looks at you and goes I was
making 143 thousand dollars a year I
went to the grocery store and couldn't
buy groceries for my one-year-old kids
party yeah and don't do this don't be
stupid
I mean how wonderful those kids are
they're getting they're not just getting
a class out of this they're getting
wisdom mm-hmm that's also oh they are
they are there's no question that's an
inspiring story because it does it
there's something snapped you had that
on I've had it moment I'm not doing this
anymore and then he got it to within 24
hours and it just like boom and then you
guys go hog-wild together you just laid
your ears back and went oh yeah and one
of the best things I heard more recently
on on your show I have it on every day
just everywhere I'm going and it's it
was if it's hard now it's gonna be a lot
more fun then and if it's easy now it's
gonna be a lot harder than Kenan I think
the example you used was the car so you
could finance it real easy now it's
really hard to own that car later and
it's really helped me hit home for a lot
of other people using that type of
analysis has been it's just been fun
that's Kara it's pretty cool that's cool
yeah a lot of stuff by the time I paid
it off I hated it oh yeah I know it's a
whole different ball game now it's fun
to go like I can't the power cache is
unbelievable and and when we start doing
that process we're getting things for
half of what we used to spend for them
we'd walk in and just throw it down
finance it and be done with it now it's
like half off yeah it's almost a game
it's like well yeah that's fun what can
we get this for you know using cash as
well and when you work that hard Ford
has real money you just go uh-huh you
can't have it yeah get a deal we're not
doing the thing well very cool we talked
about people just finding money in the
process and we were planning the trip to
Nashville and she comes to me and she
goes something's off with our budget
there's like 500 hours I can't account
for and I'm thinking we're short and we
were 500 extra laying around that we
didn't know where it came
I love it that's exactly how it works
manage money works harder all right
Justin and Lauren Logan and Sydney from
Chicago $85,000 paid off in seventeen
and a half months making 143 to 222
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream you ready ready three two this is
the Dave Ramsey show